un
vélo électrique cargo des sceaux à son
bord cédric s'active sur son cycle au
composteur pour la deuxième collecte de
déchets végétaux de la semaine première
étape un restaurant de l'hyper centre
ville d'orléans
cette semaine plus de poireaux carottes
quelques +2 pas me taire voilà eh ben
c'est bien mais merci beaucoup
on trie déjà depuis plus de dix ans
après on ne triait pas du tout les
végétaux on les mélange est en effet
avec la poubelle verte on aurait aimé
que la ville d'orléans ne trouve des
solutions plus rapidement aujourd'hui ce
sont les cyclos poster qui ont mis la
main à la pâte on va dire et on va faire
tout pour que ça se passe bien avec eux
et donnait aussi à la ville d'orléans
l'envi qu'ils nous accompagnent dans ce
projet - j'ai de déchets à jeter dans ma
poubelle verte moi je vais utiliser de
sacs poubelles moi je vais utiliser
d'eau pour la nettoyer à l'arrivée donc
à l'arrivée c'est même plutôt
rien un gain de temps
avec plus de 300 établissements de
bouche à orléans les perspectives de
développement de l'éco activités sont
très prometteuses et les marchands de
fleurs commencent eux aussi à comprendre
son intérêt
il ya trois fleuristes actuellement qui
nous font confiance plutôt qu'ils
aillent en déchetterie déposées de leurs
déchets en fait on vient on vient les
chercher directement en boutique alors
gagner du temps direction maintenant le
site de compostage pour déposer les
végétaux l'odeur qui s'en dégage est
plutôt agréable
d'un compost bien fait ne sont pas en
général quand il ya une odeur c'est
c'est un indicateur qu'il ya quelque
chose qui a été mal mélanger du coup on
revient à intervenir dessus et au bout
de trois mois en fait on va le mettre en
maturation y mettra il mettra six mois
rend tout le processus mais à neuf mois
et les restaurateurs et fleuristes
peuvent alors le récupérer depuis le
printemps 5 tonnes de bio déchets ont
été collectées et valorisées par
l'association qui emploie deux salariés